eine durchschnittstemperatur von minus
55 grad celsius extreme staubstürme und
eine wirklich dünne atmosphäre all das
führt dazu dass das leben auf dem mars
ziemlich ungemütlich wäre dennoch
beherbergt der rote planet wasser und
gilt somit als potenzieller raum für
leben eine spektakuläre entdeckung
offenbart jetzt die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass sich in tieferen maß
gesteinsschichten organismen befinden
ist alles andere als klein ein hund an
einem der lebensbedrohlichen orte der
erde liegt nämlich nahe dass organismen
im wasser das fohlen mars entstanden
sein könnten und bis heute überlebt
haben
links um science fiction die gibt's
täglich faszinierendes 1 videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst er
nicht herzlich willkommen ja hier so
sage ich ganz schön machen da war er in
köln dann bin ich nämlich im moment aber
das spanische forschungsteam hatte an
einem der lebensbedrohlichen gebiete der
erde nach leben gesucht und zwar im
nordosten von äthiopien
hier gibt es das geothermal gebiet da
rollen
dieser ort ist wirklich extrem gruselig
und unwirklich zudem stinkt es
bestialisch diese landschaft wird völlig
zurecht auch als ort ohne wiederkehr
oder als eingang zur hölle bezeichnet
denn in dieser vulkanlandschaft sprudelt
tatsächlich säure aus dem boden
zudem werden hier die höchsten
durchschnittlichen jahrestemperaturen
der erde gemessen im ersten moment
könnte man tatsächlich denken dass man
sich auf einem fremden planeten befindet
die gegend ist umgeben von aktiven
vulkanen und das grundwasser wird durch
magna erhitzt beim aufsteigen löst es
die 1000 meter dicken salz und anhydrit
schichten mineralien auf diese lagern
sich an der oberfläche ab und bilden so
die salz türme den kuriosen und
verschiedenartigen form bei austritt
haben die salzwasser quellen eine
temperatur von 100 9 grad celsius im
wasser und den boden liegt der ph wert
unter 1 das bedeutet einen extrem hohen
säuregehalt an den heißesten stellen
dieses lebensbedrohlichen gebietes nahm
das agro biologie team um verliebte
gomez proben um diese dann im labor zu
analysieren mit hilfe einer chemischen
analyse einer dna sequenzierung und der
verwendung an
elektronenmikroskops machten die
fachleute eine erstaunliche entdeckung
in den proben spürten sie nämlich
winzige kugelförmige strukturen auf
winzigen mikro wie mit der bezeichnung
nano archäo ta einzellige organismen die
hier überleben und das schon seit vielen
hunderttausend jahren dazu der
astrobiologe verliehen bekommen dies ist
eine exotische wirklich extrem umgebung
mit organismen die hohe temperaturen
einen hohen salzgehalt und einen sehr
niedrigen ph-wert aushalten müssen um zu
überleben
diese entdeckung bereit sich in einige
weitere erstaunliche erkenntnis in
diesem zusammenhang ein denn auf der
erde wurden schon zahlreiche wirklich
denkbar lebensfernen sich orte
aufgespürt wo es trotz extremer kälte
oder hitze von organismen nur so wimmeln
zb bei 122 grad celsius in heißen
quellen und auch das andere extrem ist
möglich selbst hunderte meter unter dem
am gletscher 1 ist leben möglich und es
wird noch krasser lange für nicht
möglich gehalten aber dennoch war auch
im havarierten kernreaktoren wie
tschernobyl wachsen pilze und das
verrückte daran die erde selbst hat im
laufe ihrer klimageschichte quasi immer
wieder selbst dafür gesorgt dass sie
weiter von neben gewohnt bleibt studien
legen nahe dass die erde in gewissem
maße ihre temperatur selbst regulieren
kann extrem kalten zeiten hat sie quasi
entgegengewirkt in dem vulkane
kohlendioxid ausgestoßen haben und sich
die erde dadurch wieder ein stück weiter
erwärmt bei anhaltender trockenheit
dagegen sank gestein weiter ab und nahm
damit co2 aus der atmosphäre
sie ließen die lufttemperatur sinken
einfach leute diese erkenntnisse von
knapp 25 jahren aus dem weltall
projizierten man sie vom ergebnis selbst
überrascht in unserem sonnensystem
solche in dem nachkriegs zur umlaufbahn
des mars nieden möglich sein auch wenn
er selbst alles andere als
lebensfreundlich geht und auch die
aktuelle entdeckung von nach utah in dem
äthiopischen geothermal gebiet
unterstreicht noch einmal organismen
sind extrem widerstands und
anpassungsfähig und so in der lage auch
unter eigentlich unmöglichen bedingungen
leben im klartext heißt das also auch
die uv-strahlung der sonne könnte
organismen in tiefen gesteinsschichten
des mars vielleicht nichts anhaben
organisches leben könnte einst im
ursprünglich noch flüssigem wasser des
roten planeten entstanden sein und bis
heute überlebt haben die wirklich extrem
fundorte von organismen auf der erde
sprechen eindeutig dafür dass
organisches leben auf dem mars sogar
über milliarden jahre hinweg ausgehalten
haben könnten dazu die wissenschaftlerin
barbara kavala sie aus bologna eine
detaillierte untersuchung der merkmale
dieser erstaunlichen region wird unser
verständnis der grenzen des lebens auf
der erde verbessern und für unsere suche
nach leben auf dem mars und anderswo im
universum extrem hilfreich sein
in einem weiteren schritt möchten das
forschungsteam jetzt herausfinden wie
die nun aufgespürten nano bakterien es
schaffen in einer solch extremen
umgebungen zu überleben auch eine
spannende erkenntnisse aus dem sommer
2008 zehn machte die entdeckung von
leben auf dem mars ein bisschen
wahrscheinlicher denn damals hatte ein
italienisches forschungsteam einen rund
20 kilometer breiten sie aus flüssigem
wasser unter dem eis des südpols
aufgespürt schon damals zeigten die
daten in dieser apfel grenzen region
dieselben signaturen wie sehen unter dem
eis den polarregionen der erde und in
unterirdischen seen die beispielsweise
in dem lake willens in der antarktis
wimmelt es nur so von mikroben bedeutet
das etwa dass die existenz von leben
auch in diesem gletschersee das war es
eine klare sache ist flüssiges wasser
ist schließlich die grundvoraussetzung
für leben wie wir es kennen
die fachwelt ist sich weiter nicht
sicher denn darauf konnten die radar
beobachtung keine direkten hinweise
geben höchstwahrscheinlich ist es laut
der fachleute aber dass unterirdisches
flüssiges wasser auf dem mars auch an
anderer stelle vorkommen können aliens
dinosaurier sein anklicken anschauen und
astronom ins tv abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran jetzt wird ziemlich
hier etwas unglücklich
schlitz